the last thing i wanted to bring up was
something that all of us are grappling
with right now
talking to someone who doesn't agree
with you
wanting to
change their perception maybe convince
them
and it feels like we're in a place in
our country
where someone's with you or they're not
someone's in
your group or they're in the other group
and
i'm just saying this as a i'm i'm i'm
trying to address
everybody with this if you're a rabid
trump supporter
uh or if you think he's the antichrist
how can we get to a place where we can
talk about these things
you can't shout someone down and yell at
them and intimidate them into agreeing
with you
uh about some of these issues so what do
you do
yeah it's the uh it's the it's the
age-old question
um i think you make you make
strategic smart choices that
conserve your energy and protect your
humanity
and and also
good uses of your energy right um and so
i think that sometimes i will say that
i've never ever
ever seen an argument be one in a
facebook thread
no have you ever seen it happen i've
never seen online anyone go you know
what
i've been thinking about it and you're
right
ufos don't exist
so i think there can be when you really
believe something and you're seeing
not stuff online it's very tempting to
get into it i
at this point in my world i don't
do that your hair looks great by the way
it's incredible you know i think that
should be the most important thing
everyone takes away from this
conversation
it is conan's hair and then race
relations in america
i have my priorities straight yeah you
know maybe you could like
we could like spray paint black lives
matter onto your hair then it could just
be always there
right okay all right we can do that
sort of an orange sometimes i found for
people who have family members
um especially maybe older generation
family members who they're
they want to be able to connect with
over this but it's hard sometimes
connecting through history
um through like historical events can be
a kind of way in um to get to those
conversations
and i also think that we have to accept
that we're just not gonna change
everybody's mind
um and i don't think i don't there's
people who disagree with me i do not
think that you
that we are under and that we are
obligated to get into
long drawn-out conversations with people
who don't respect the basic humanity
of the people that we love you know um
and that said i think that if you do see
someone online
who you know and you you want to engage
with them or
or it's a family member asking people if
they're willing to talk to you offline
you know hey i have a different opinion
and i'd be really interested in sharing
about
like what i believe would you ever be
willing to talk to me you know
privately or on the phone you know um
and and if you can come i mean i think
that for people who are interested in
having those conversations
learning the basics of non-violent
communication is incredibly helpful
because i agree with you
you're not going to shout people you
know and it can go from zero to like
10 million so quickly because people get
so upset actually right
especially right now i mean it's always
been that way but right now it feels
definitely like a powder keg and we're
seeing every day we talked about this
before
on social media people have even taken
wearing
masks face masks as a basic protection
they've somehow made that
an issue that they've tied to uh
you know um race or uh
uh income wealth they've tied it to all
this other st
freedom uh government versus no
government
and it's like no no just put on a mask
it's really simple
just put on a mask but no that's
what we've we've if if people are losing
it over
wearing a piece of paper over their
mouth for the 10 minutes that they're at
a costco
we see what's gonna happen when you're
implying that they're
part of a racist system that needs to be
uh
that needs to be fixed they're gonna
really lose it
that's where you choose your battles
right that's where you choose is this
going to be worth the energy that it's
going to take me
and could i use my energy elsewhere i'll
tell you that you know a lot of people
that i talk to who have struggled with
really racist family members
you the aunt and uncle grandma grandpa
the parents they may be far gone but
those nieces and nephews those little
cousins you know
right send them my books you know have
those conversations like you said about
your kids like they're
a different generation so sometimes i
think maybe it's if you're the aunt
connecting with that niece or nephew um
in a way that doesn't like
you know the parents but uh don't talk
to any of my relatives that's how i take
care of it
that's all my manager talks to everyone
for me you know
he tells me they're lovely people
the other thing i'd say is sometimes i
think about
talking to people who don't get it or
who you disagree with
you know it's almost like talking to my
almost seven-year-old son
where i have to remind myself that we're
gonna have a lot of conversations where
what i say in the moment may not seem to
change anything with him
but it's going to sink in over time
right i think that it's still worth
doing your best to share resources
recommend books recommend documentaries
maybe the back and forth on facebook
isn't going to change anything but like
maybe you can get that aunt to listen to
the 1619
podcast you know or to watch when they
see us or to watch
13th you know maybe just putting those
resources
out there um maybe that can work with
someone over time and they might not
change their mind in the moment that
you're in the conversation
but stuff could sink in that's how i
feel about parenting basically at all
times
right well uh i appreciate this
conversation
a lot i like to be an optimist
and i i uh i like to know that good
people are out there
trying to do good work and so i'm uh
wait i have one more question i know
we're done but uh
i am curious to know like what is one
thing that you learned from my book that
you
were like fascinated to learn as a
history book that you didn't know before
well i'm going to say maya lynn what i
didn't know was that maya lin was in
college when she designed the vietnam
memorial and that she got
that much opposition to it and that she
fought back
what college student who was told yes
we're going to build your monument we
just need you to make a few changes says
i don't think so it's good the way it is
and then it turned out to be such a
stunning success
that's one of the coolest uh i mean the
books the books filled with very amazing
stories
that was the one that stuck with me
because i was so shocked that
someone that young um it just had the
guts and temerity
and vision and then saw it all the way
through and then it turned into a
massive success
in her lifetime immediately not like man
not like van gogh like where okay
maybe he's a ghost somewhere and he's
appreciating and his stuff is making a
lot of money
he's a one-eared ghost but uh yeah
i i really love that excellent van ghost
van ghost exactly all right i'll do the
comedy here